all right y'all it's almost time to say
goodbye but do not worry we have one
more story to share this is what I'm
liking so I love getting to know the
music scene here in New York this city
has always been a magnet for upand
cominging performers an artist
Collective known as Keepsake house
continues that tradition each live show
mixes songwriting with storytelling
creating a Keepsake experience for the
audience super cool let's get the
founders in here everybody say hello to
Haley and Jasmine
what's up y'all so Haley I'm gonna start
with you you came up with the idea right
yeah both of us did so I'm an event
planner and Jasmine's a musician from
New York um and we sort of saw this need
to have a more community space for
Independent Artists here especially bipo
and lgbtq plus artists um because it's
so competitive in the city um so we
started Keepsake house which is a home
for IND dependent artists to share the
stage and make music with meaning all of
our shows bring together songwriters and
storytellers they share the stage and
learn from each other um and they also
benefit other like-minded organizations
so we've actually raised over $7,000 for
asian-pacific American mental health
focused organizations W that's so cool
and um thank you and yeah ultimately we
just want to be a home that feels safe
and supportive for anyone comes into it
whether a performer or an audience
absolutely this is look I lived in
Nashville for like nearly 15 years this
reminds me of like walking in like
Bluebird or a place like that like they
have them everywhere there and you see
these these stories these songs we told
these artists with the song writers it's
a very cool experience did y'all kind of
take a page from that Jasmine yeah um
haly and I both have visited Nashville
and love that that City and one of the
things we love most about it is the
round T style shows that they have there
with multiple artists on stage AG taking
turns playing their songs um we love
sort of the openness and collaboration
behind that and wanted to bring that to
New York um and actually Kelly we live
stream all of our shows and we have one
coming up on Friday this week uh at pink
frog in Williamsburg New York um but you
can watch it anywhere so if you're
around we'd love to see you oh that's
incredible and I can I just say it's so
cool too like you're seeing something
different every time you'all do these
shows like these are different
songwriters different stories different
just moments I think that's so special
you know like you're not seeing the same
thing all the time like you know
sometimes when you go on tour to see
artist that's what you get you know and
I think it's really cool that you're
like specializing it for the audience
it's very cool yeah thank you we always
say you you'll never see another show
like it because you won't see that set
of artists um on together like in a in a
time where everything is always online
right after it's done it's hard to
create that kind of experience so well
done and and such a good cause as well
thank you so much Jasmine thank you
Haley un liking your post right now and
that's not all our season long partner
pilot pin makers of friction the goto R
pin of the Kelly Clarkson show want to
celebrate creators just like yourselves
so they're giving you $1,000 that's $500
each just to help out in whatever way it
can thank you so much and thank you to
all our guests this hour Brie Larson
Brandy Clark Alan Stewart David Arenberg
Cash Warren and Daniel ctis yall a great
thing if it's not try and
[Applause]
changing
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home